The Marvel Cinematic Universe may have seemed
like a risk at the beginning, but the release
of Iron Man, and the many box office successes
that followed soon made Marvel's pipe dream
a reality.
The comic book heroes and villains kept on
marching to the big screen, but no matter
how fantastic, how dark, or how grounded the
stories got, audiences could trust that a
Marvel movie would always deliver some memorable
action scenes.
Some movies through Marvel's Phase One and
Two have raised the bar more than others,
but even the less-successful films have turned
in at least a handful of memorable scenes.
Here is our look at the 20 Greatest Action
Scenes From Marvel's Phase One & Two.
Iron Man - The Cave Escape
It's only fair that we start at the beginning,
when Tony Stark first introduced the world
to his alter ego: Iron Man.
The Mark 1 armor may not be as polished as
the ones that came after, but striking from
the darkness, unleashing flamethrowers, and
making his first aerial escape proved in a
single scene that Marvel's second-rate hero
could be box office gold.
The Incredible Hulk - Big Man on Campus
Fans of Marvel's big green monster were counting
the minutes to see him in all his glory, and
when Thunderbolt Ross cornered Bruce Banner
to force the Hulk out of hiding, he got more
than he bargained for - and fans got a fantastic
sequence.
Watching Hulk take down Humvees, sonic cannons,
and even a gunship still never gets old.
The Incredible Hulk - Harlem Shake
The campus battle was just an appetizer, since
the creation of the Hulk-sized Abomination
gave the green hero the real villain of his
first (and so far, only) solo MCU story.
It was everything you want from a battle of
monsters: cars used as boxing gloves, entire
buildings as nothing but hurdles, and even
Hulk's fire-quenching super-clap (near the
end of the fight, putting out the fire of
Betty's chopper crash).
Recasting the role for The Avengers may lead
some people to think Hulk's first movie was
a wash, but these scenes and more stand the
test of time.
Captain America - Ride on The Valkyrie
There were plenty of fights in the wartime
setting of Captain America, but the film saved
the biggest spectacle for its final act.
Starting with the daring leap onto the bomber,
the ensuing fight saw Cap battle onto, through,
outside of, and then back into the plane,
leading to a final showdown with Red Skull.
It's the film's best action - the fact that
it leads into Cap's so-called death only makes
it more watchable.
Thor - Frost Giant Frenzy
No Marvel hero had a bigger hill to climb
than the god of thunder, but his first solo
film wasted no time in showing that he wasn't
just deadly with his hammer - but the more
intense the fight, the wider the grin on his
face.
Smashing skulls alongside the Warriors Three,
Thor's mocking screams, and devastating lightning
attacks showed what fans could expect - even
if he needed his daddy to come to his rescue.
The Avengers - Shakespeare in the Park
When an Asgardian is taken into custody, some
hiccups are to be expected.
So when Thor first arrives to confiscate Loki
from Iron Man, the billionaire takes exception.
The fight that followed between Stark and
Thor was actually storyboarded before director
Joss Whedon even joined the film, which means
Marvel knew from the start that the heavyweight
rumble would be the perfect way to bring the
Avengers' big three onto the same page - and
they were right.
The Avengers - Attack on the Helicarrier
In Marvel's first team-up, the stakes couldn't
have been higher.
It was lucky, then, that Loki was just the
kind of villain to hatch a plan sending every
member of the team into battle on different
fronts.
The Helicarrier fight remains one of the most
diverse in the MCU: Hulk first threatens Widow,
before Thor takes on the monster himself.
Cap trades bullets with enemy soldiers, Fury
holds down the bridge, and Tony gets a close-up
look at the inside of the Helicarrier's turbine.
Pick your favorite scene: it's one homerun
after another.
Captain America: The Winter Soldier - Fury's
Ambush
Since he doesn't have any superpowers, audiences
were riveted to see Nick Fury cornered and
ambushed by enemy forces in Washington, D.C..
The gadgets that allowed Fury to escape, and
the slower-speed, but insanely tense chase
scene that followed made The Winter Solider
a hit almost by themselves, delivering an
action scene to stand up against the best
of any genre, let alone comic book movies.
Iron Man 3 - Barrel of Monkeys
One of Tony Stark's greatest action scenes
didn't actually require any firepower at all:
instead, he had to save the lives of over
a dozen people freefalling from Air Force
One.
Using actual skydivers to get realistic footage,
and incredible CG to polish it up, the scene
was one of the most adrenaline-pumping in
Stark's career - even more impressive, since
he wasn't even IN the armor when he completed
the mission.
Captain America: The Winter Soldier - Stealthy
at Sea
Shifting Steve Rogers from the old war to
the new one could have been tricky, but when
his sequel kicked off, he was already a master
of covert ops and silent takedowns.
Using his feet, fists and shield to put down
an entire ship's crew himself, things only
got better as he drew the leader out in the
open.
The directors made the most of UFC champion
Georges St-Pierre, pitting him against Cap
in one of the simplest, but most memorable
fights in the MCU.
Iron Man 3 - House Party Protocol
Iron Man 3 might have taken Tony out of the
suit for most of the movie, but the final
act more than made up for it by calling in
the cavalry to help the hero save the day.
The cavalry, being every single specialized
suit of armor Stark had made, piloted remotely
by his A.I. co-pilot, JARVIS.
Seeing Tony leap from one suit to another
was a truly inspired idea, but watching as
the suits take down their enemies in their
own special way always offers something new
on repeat viewings.
Captain America: The Winter Soldier - The
Elevator
When Fury falls, Cap's not far behind.
The elevator fight - which the directors compared
to watching ten men try to fight a gorilla
in a cage - was the first sequence to be shot,
taking more than four days.
The results spoke for themselves, with Cap's
brutal up-close skills not just making the
scene incredible in the film, but actually
used to market the film as a first teaser.
Thor: The Dark World - Prologue
The opening prologue of a fantasy movie is
supposed to be good - but maybe not THIS good.
The sequence, following Asgardians of old
defeating the Dark Elves, was created by director
Tim Miller's own studio, years before he would
helm Deadpool.
The talent at work is obvious, since the CG-fueled
battle scenes are massive, fluid, and above
all, more entertaining and undeniably badass
- in a Lord of the Rings sort of way - than
any of the fights in the rest of the movie.
Captain America: The Winter Soldier - Bucky's
Back
It was only a matter of time until Steve and
Bucky went head-to-head, and when they did,
the bullets and smashed glass didn't disappoint.
From Widow swinging from bridges to Cap being
smashed through city buses, the scene - and
Bucky's knife skills - kept fans on the edge
of their seats.
The reveal that Steve's new enemy was his
former best friend only guaranteed the scene
would never be forgotten - even though it
was never really a risk.
The Avengers: Age of Ultron - Hulk, Meet Veronica
It's hard to choose one fight from the Avengers'
second team-up, since the movie is really
one battle after another.
But considering how long comic book fans were
hoping to see Tony Stark's Hulkbuster armor
- a suit able to withstand, and defeat Hulk
- the final reveal is hard to beat.
Especially with the added on-call part replacement,
making it even easier to beat Hulk by smashing
him through a skyscraper - one floor at a
time.
Guardians of the Galaxy - The Kyln
Everyone loves a prison break, but the one
featured in James Gunn's space opera turned
out so well, so funny, and so perfectly tailored
to show each character's personality, Marvel
actually ended up releasing the sequence as
a free preview ahead of release.
The response was even stronger in the finished
movie, when Rocket, Quill, Gamora, Groot and
Drax all showed that being a killing machine
doesn't mean you can't be hilarious, too.
Thor: The Dark World - Fun With Portals
The battle between Thor and Malekith may not
be as clear or satisfying as his fellow Avengers'
biggest fights, but that doesn't mean it isn't
just as much fun to watch.
As the two men fight, the random, invisible
portals between this realm and others send
the pair tumbling from one planet to another,
from dirt to sky and back again.
For innovation alone, the scene deserves serious
credit.
Guardians of the Galaxy - Xandar's Defense
Audiences didn't know what to expect when
Star-Lord teamed up with the Ravagers, but
what they got was a one-of-a-kind aerial attack,
sending an entire fleet of scavenger ships
to outsmart one massive cruiser.
James Gunn turned to dogfighting references
instead of space ships, and the benefits show.
Plus, once the dogfighting ends, it's time
for the Nova Corps' heroic arrival, and for
Rocket and the Ravagers to play a little live-action
Space Invaders to protect the civilians on
the ground.
forget Marvel - this is one of the best action
sequences in years, period.
Ant-Man - Small Scale Showdown
From the very first trailers for Marvel's
most unlikely hero, it was obvious the idea
of a shrinking superhero would be played for
laughs.
The final fights between Ant-Man and Yellow
Jacket didn't have to be fought on ant-scale,
but the model trains and harmless kids' toys
being turned into completely new weapons meant
action and comedy - a perfect mix that made
Ant-Man a welcome addition to a shared universe
already filled with heroes.
The Avengers - Battle of New York
Is it cheating when a movie turns its entire
third act into one massive fight sequence?
Who cares: the battle of New York was everything
a comic book fan could have dreamed of: Cap
leaping over cars and rescuing hostages, Thor
unleasing lightning from New York skyscrapers,
Iron Man flying through urban valleys at breakneck
speed, and Hulk... smashing.
The cherry on top came in the sweeping shot
flowing from one Avenger to another, not to
mention the spinning look at the team that
cemented them as Hollywood legends.
Those are the fight scenes from Marvel's first
two phases that most stick out in our memory,
but which ones are your favorites?
Some memorable ones had to be left off our
list, but make sure to mention them in the
comments, and remember to subscribe for more
videos like this one!